buried in the middle of all this was the
announcement that
kamal harris our vice president is going
to lead the immigration effort
she's going to lead the border
investigation
and there's a lot of voices out there
that said that she wasn't
selected to be vice president he ended
up with her
vice president that the whole mechanism
and the whole
say that one more time he was what she
was not supposed to she was not
selected by him to be vice president he
ended up with her vice president because
the whole democrat
party apparatus was like hey we got to
have a woman show him a color there's a
lot of good reasons for sure
so every little girl in america could
look up and say hey look i can become
vice president i can do that
that's very very positive but there are
forces out there to say hey you know
biden ended up with her he didn't
necessarily want her
and the best place to her there's now
voices saying hey is she being set up to
fail did you hear some of this yesterday
yeah
what do you think being said the
appointments that she was
yeah there's democrat voices that are
saying hey she shouldn't be in charge of
immigration like this is a leadership
issue you should
is she being set up to fail i i don't
think she's being set up to fail i just
think she
was selected by others i don't think she
was selected by
biden i agree with you there yep let me
let me ask you do you think
obama picked biden
let me ask a question a different way
let me ask a question this way here's a
better way of asking a question
what percentage of obama picking biden
was him so you can say
i think it's 70 30 obama or 50 50 obama
50 the dnc okay well i was i was a a
freshman senator but i i remember
meeting joe
good guy friendly guy effective in the
senate long
tenure and uh it was about 62 and a half
percent
my decision so you're you're going to
say so you're going to say majority was
obama's decision
i think madrid i think the majority was
obama's decision but he was heavily
influenced because he was
walking into a room he'd never been
before this is a freshman senator i
i think okay let's say 62 percent is
what you're what would you say i was
going to say 75 25. oh so you think it's
him picking on the bible no
the other way okay how about you go to
uh uh trump
do you think he picked pence or do you
think somebody else picked pence for him
i think somebody else picked pence for
him what do you think is a percentage
with him and pence i
i would say the same presented because
who can really uh be the parent in the
room when it come when it came to trump
okay what do you think tom pence uh i
think pence was a safe vanilla choice he
got a lot of
uh help doing but i don't think anybody
tells donald trump what to do so so okay
so you're saying
uh 90 trump 10 whoever told them that
these are the options
okay donald trump i can see that you
need an ohio you need an ohio indiana
guy to balance it off you're a new
yorker let's get another
video indiana midwest guy appealing
great choice by the way if you think
about it
christian guy not a lot of controversy
let's see if you can go with that donald
all right let me think about that okay
did bush pick his vp
george w george w what percent i think
the bush political family was well
established and i don't think they
needed help from the republican party
and i think they picked dick cheney for
a lot of reasons do you think he picked
it or the family picked dick cheney
i think he got a lot of help from papa
so what percentage was uh
was bush i think bush was probably about
25
seconds okay so it's probably his dad
okay so clinton pick and gore who picked
them
what percentage is bill clinton pick and
gore i think the same thing i think
democrat party said hey
you know you're southern you know this
guy's a good senator he's got more
experience than you do you're just a
governor remember he was just a governor
yeah
you get a guy from washington arkansas
so and then so you took this
neutral tennessee guy that didn't have a
lot of controversy gordon
remember people i i don't think in those
positions anybody
regardless of what party i don't think
the presidential candidate has much
of a selection of who the one is the
vice president i i think some
some is more than others i think
sometimes more than i fully believe some
is more than others
like i fully believe uh a
you know or what do you call it a reagan
is a guy that went in saying hey here's
kind of who i like
uh to be my guy and he was given
feedback by james baker with his options
and they sit there and they process it
and then he says here's who i'm picking
okay great so
and there's a lot of negotiation on
picking as well like when
kennedy picked lyndon johnson it was all
strategy because lyndon johnson
hated kennedy so kennedy wanted to get
rid of one of his biggest
enemies his number one enemy which is
who and the fastest way to turn an enemy
into an allies to what hey will you be
my vp
and he says i really don't want to be
your vp man you know the hell with you i
should be the president
you should even consider being my vp but
i get it let's make this work and they
needed texas so the electoral vote math
was there
remember that thing was close yeah so
here's the magical question what
percentage of
biden was him picking kamala yeah
twenty percent i disagree i totally
disagree
zero percent what do you think it was on
the same thing as the party
i think it's zero percent biden pick and
kamala yeah
i i think and the reason why it's zero
percent is because biden didn't win the
election
the party did correct biden didn't win
the election
trump won the election okay bill clinton
won the election
if you think about that bush the party
won the election
i i don't know if i'm making sense
i also think obama had a lot of same
pick and biden
because obama won the election when
obama ran for office don't forget
everybody was banking on who
hillary to win okay they weren't saying
obama's going to win it was like hillary
is going to win so
obama won that election so whoever wins
the election i feel
has more of a say on who becomes mvp
than the party
versus whoever whatever party wins it
and they choose the candidate
the party chooses who's going to be your
vp i think biden was zero percent him
choosing
kamala biden was just told come on lost
your vp
what do you think the percentage of
somebody picking a vp just to get over
the finish line
or versus somebody that would be good
fit for them for the four years
okay so if you go back and think about
who the vp candidates were for uh for
uh biden who were some of the ones that
were good candidates
uh do you remember the names rice
exactly who else
obviously okay if you have a choice
between susan rice and kamala harris who
do you go with
are you 50 50. yeah i'm probably 50 50
because i'm not really a big fan of
either one of them
um you know minnesota what a great
choice
minnesota would have been a great choice
okay yeah minnesota or michigan
no minnesota oh menace oh i'm sorry i
thought you said the uh
yeah that's that's what i thought you
said uh i thought
tulsi would have been an amazing they
would have never picked tulsi
first tulsi says what's on her mind they
wouldn't have you're asking me yeah as
an american i
looked there and saying you know veteran
leading a state even though it's why
i i would have admired that choice
yeah so to go back to it when you're
asking a question about kamala harris do
you hear about what kamal harris did
yesterday like
working on women and women empowerment
you know who he
she reached out to for advice who's that
bill clinton wow
what is that confusing or what am i the
only one that's
have you guys seen this or no can you
pull up kamala harris ask bill clinton
for advice and the media flipped out
like she she's just put bill clinton
watch this here watch this here kamala
harrison bill clinton touting girl
empowerment
okay can you like that just makes no
sense
by the way and harrison bill clinton
touting girls empowerment together is a
bad
joke which news news baby which news by
the way this is nbc
correct why can't the democratic party
quit the former president if the party
is truly going to welcome women
it has to get rid of the political
milestone around its neck
millstone around this thing so i just i
just don't understand
that's why so confusing does that look
good for the party by the way no
well frankly i'm glad that any woman
calls me anymore you know
closing in on 80 here of course i put
that video in there
you know but the clinton affair by the
way this is
nbc putting this out there this is not
like anybody else putting this out there
right so
this isn't drudge or fox here no no
that's that's nbc
can we see can we see what was what the
cnn said about the headline here go go
to different headlines just go back
cnn would say so what did fox news say
so okay president
okay now go back go back fox is gonna
say just go back to where you were
before
kamala harris to a whole discussion with
bill clinton on empowering women and
girls okay fox news is actually very
neutral nbc news took the shot is a bad
joke
market watch kamala harris and bill
clinton are holding the talk about women
empowerment can you kind of go to what
the rest of the line is
q uh uh uh uh
by nasa or they don't even have it here
how funny is that everything we put in
the search doesn't come down in the news
none of it matches the new did you see
that go back and go back and do that
again
yeah no no what does that have to do
with what we searched
interesting wait go wait i'm confused
here
this is google we have to watch search
kamala harris asks bill clinton for
advice we click on news
none of the links that come up is about
what you searched on google
the google algorithm doesn't seem to
want america to see the clinton story do
that
go back up go back up to all okay i
guess now try
okay use the same exact copy paste
exactly what you have and go to yahoo
it's kind of interesting the search
engines are i'm curious
let's see what they say here just copy
paste okay
vp slated 101 with book clinton the
blaze okay so the blaze is at the top
fair enough they put the blaze out there
the washington examiner rose mcgowan
asked if kamala harris has a soul
wow do you even have a click on that
click on that click on that
actress and feminist rose mcgonagall
after agreeing to obscene event with
bill clinton on empowering women wow
that's not good guys these are all the
people that defended clinton
you have to keep them there she was
their guy well no rose mcgowan if you
know who she is she's uh um
this is obscene kamala has you speaking
with bill clinton about empowering women
and girls is disgusting have you know so
have you no ethics ask him about being
on an island of human trafficking
victims 27 times you're showing us
exactly who you are
go back go back and let's see what other
sites we'll see you know as i analyze
that from rose mcgowan
i have a small sense that's kind of
growing on me that she's upset
it's going lower go lower go lower go
live
okay david ike.com comes up well you got
to be kidding me okay
how was he doing look at that so you
know
so i i don't know
the question i would have is who the
hell is advising them right now
that's what i'm asking so you have a
meeting and you say i'm thinking about
putting a girl empowerment meeting
together oh you should call bill clinton
by the way you should be right do you
know how the media knows this huh the
media knows this because every day
you know there are agendas that are put
out for the potus
what's potus doing today in the media's
given agenda he will be here going here
and then there's things they leave up
the agenda and they get criticized
because there's a billion dollar donor
that was at the white house during that
half hour you were talking about that
yeah
so now the vice president united states
agenda
had that on it the only way they find
out about this is either clinton leaks
it
or it was already on the activity agenda
that's given to the media so they can
cover the uh
president vice president it's common
sense so it means that to your point
who's advising them there's also
somebody in there yeah yeah we'll put
the clinton thing on there what's the
worst that could happen
if there's any criticism a private
conversation with bill clinton could she
have it
private meaning just make a phone call
nobody knows you're talking to her
correct absolutely
sure so wait you're saying somebody set
them up is what you're saying no no i'm
saying that
her team you're asking who's advising
and i'm like that instinct i think is
absolutely correct here because her
daily agenda that's released to the
media
if i was her advisor i would say you
know you shouldn't put a phone call on
there
have a private phone call get political
you know advice from him
on how to manage these situations but
for the love of god
what advice could he give what advice
can he really give her
so spin it actually actually think your
kamala and spin it
spin it i'm a media i'm asking and i'm
not i'm not saying be funny about it
i'm not being comical i'm actually
saying spin it
spin it and say hey uh vice president
kamala harris
out of all the people you could have
chosen to speak to about a matter of
women empowerment
you have oprah winfrey you have uh you
know
uh michelle obama you have uh you know
uh
even hillary hillary clinton you have
susan rice you have
you have you have a number of women to
go to you have daughters
yeah vice president come on harris
why why president bill clinton with the
reputation that he has i don't know how
to spin it because i don't know
why with that list you just made he
would be number
87 on my political advice 1 000 million
87
so but how do you actually try to spin
that one how do you spend that one
i think it was just incredibly bad
judgment tom that can't that i don't buy
that i i don't buy that because
i i have a hard time buying that i have
a hard time buying
well he's the he is a shrewd politician
and very smart strategically politically
but still the consequence is this that
we just saw
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye